oh
[Musique]
évidemment
béziers d'un renflouement pouvoir
là
[Musique]
l'animal
hier
à l'abattoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à noronha ligue et rigueur attendue a
reçu parce que c'était vraiment une
artiste qu'on adore on a reçu vanille et
c'est vrai qu'à un moment je me suis dit
pourquoi on reçoit pas chocolat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
mais ça normalement c'est mon mathieu
s'hydrater c'est ce qui s'est passé est
ce qu'on pourra s'hydrater non on va
travailler nombre à s'hydrater pendant
les pubs
[Musique]
parce que pour aller boire un coup
pendant les pubs
[Musique]
allez voir la vidéo du doigt dessus
c'est l'heure c'est énorme
reste que l'ancien un jeu tout à fait
doc dot énervé du japon le défend sa
liste et alors je suis la grèce ça
m'énerve ça m'aiderait soir joue en fait
s'il est malade n'a surtout pas que ça
aille plus loin et lolotte conforme à ce
que tu parles réserves devraient ya
quatre siècles et chaud ici on va le
refroidir tous les dernières pluies ces
derniers mois encore non ça colle assez
bien moi je retourne
reviens de vie des animaux qui apporte
même silhouette aller voir les français
ont parlé sexualité c'est un quiz
[Musique]
en fait on s'emballe ecc couscous à la
playa supplément avis comme kelly dette
par alain y en as droit plus de merde on
mange avec les doigts rouille et on peut
sur un stade à dunkerque ou à djerba
[Musique]